why are there so many scary chemicals in
your beauty products what if i told you
it's actually the other way around
popular ingredients look scarier if
you're not familiar with toxicology
which is most of us the ingredients you
hear the most scare stories about are
incredibly useful that's why they're so
popular popular ingredients get studied
more which makes sense if everyone's
using it then scientists will want to
study it first so more studies get done
on it and even if one or two of them
find something bad that's still going to
look way worse than an unpopular
ingredient with no studies on top of
that a study that sounds scary might not
actually be scary a lot of studies use
cells in a dish or they feed the
ingredient to animals lots of things
that are bad for cells and animals in
high amounts aren't bad for us when we
put it on our skin in low amounts these
studies have to be carefully translated
to realistic human impacts this is
what's done in proper safety assessments
but fear-mongering sites will just show
you the study without context on purpose
to convince you to buy different
products